good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the NCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 563 object class
Euclid special containment procedures as
all carcasses of SCP 563 a have been
removed from SCP 563 minimal containment
of SCP 563 is required it is to be
surrounded by a perimeter of motion
trackers at every 3 meters which are
remotely monitored by site 1265 a 15
kilometers away mobile task force sheet
22 codename panas barbarians is tasked
with locating and containing other
instances of scp-569 finding information
pertaining to the ancient dragon
culinary corporation currently MTF she
22 is working with the governments of
South Korea Japan and the People's
Republic of China to covertly outlaw the
trade of SCP finds 63 be instances and
recall any existing instances citing
food safety concerns the government of
the People's Republic of China is
currently collaborating with the
foundation to find sites similar to SCP
563 and locating living instances of
scp-569
SCP 563 is the designation for an
abandoned plot of farmland located in
the cuvette province China the
facilities of SCP 563 have been modified
for the factory farming of animals
weighing up to several tonnes as CP 563
is equipped mainly to handle large
poultry but other animals were raised at
the facility
SCP 563 a refers to the carcasses of the
presumed livestock of SCP 563 which were
found at the time of recovery SCP 563 a
instances were several species of
dinosaur and related reptiles that lived
in China and Mongolia in the Jurassic
and Cretaceous periods for a partial
list of recovered specimens scene log
560 305 when alive SCP 563 a instances
were presumably farmed to create
instances of scp-569 63 B is the
prehistoric food line of products made
by a company known as the ancient dragon
culinary corporation records of this
company have been found but as of
writing the location of their primary
business office and other facilities
used to make SCP 563 B are currently
unknown SCP 563 beet products are sold
in several East Asian countries but have
been discovered in some supermarket
chains in the USA various instances of
scp-569 and instant ramen made with
sweet and sour sauce and the meat of an
unknown sauropod presumably a smaller
easier to contain dinosaur similar to
abre soros don't point notably chunks of
gastroliths have been found in this
product suggesting it is partially made
with stomach meat ancient dragon
Velociraptor noodles instant noodles
made with an assortment of meat from
several dinosaurs as well as pork rice
and chunks of melon and what is
advertised to be a Velociraptor broth
testing of broth is inconclusive product
reportedly tastes like high-quality
instant noodles with high salt content
it is also the first product of the
ancient dragon culinary corporation to
be sold in the USA in the
speciality supermarket chain dragon bone
tea powder tea advertised as being made
using the bone meal of various species
of dragon DNA testing has shown that
these particles are partially derived
from non fossilized dinosaur bone but
approximately 75% of test results have
been inconclusive
to date this is the only product made by
the ancient dragon culinary corporation
that has been recalled for safety
reasons Dino snacks sold in Japan under
varying flavors marketed using
anthropomorphic dinosaur mascots
including Takara Tyrannosaurus ooh and
Risa Raptor ooh product resembles
American pork rinds testing of the
product has revealed that it is made of
several species Kentucky Fried Thor in
us or a deep-fried poultry product sold
as a frozen dinner in some parts of
South Korea as the name suggests the
meat is mostly made up of Thor in
asaurus chillin a formas reportedly
tastes like a very tough chicken kill
ryu Kogan literally dinosaur testicles
sold primarily in Japan consistently
found to be made out of meat of
pterosaurs of the gentle Lapras genus
advertised to increase sexual stamina
and fertility in both men and women
other non-anomalous products in this
line include gingko soup candied fern
leaves and steamed buns made with fish
records found pertaining to the ancient
dragon culinary corporation list SCP 563
as production farm 22 investigations
into the existence of the other 21 plus
farms and other facilities related to
SCP 563 is currently ongoing
log 560 305 a partial log of deceased
specimens of a CP 563 a a group of
microraptor's yaoi honest found on a
locked shed near the central office of
the farm injuries indicated that they
were shot at close range with ten
millimeter rounds notably two instances
were found to be still alive
having avoided fatal injuries from the
gunshots and surviving on the carcasses
of the deceased instances all instances
were found to have been wearing pet
college several hundred instances of jal
operas ninjin jens's presumably in an
artificial nest found that a large metal
shed cause of death not immediately
obvious testing showed that all
instances had been exposed to cyanide
gas the carcasses of several species of
unidentified sauropod immolated found in
a field surrounded by a highly powerful
and tall approximately 5 meter electric
fence the fence was found active upon
containment of SCP 563 and contact with
it resulted in several injuries to
recovery Force member burnt remains of
several ceratopsian dinosaurs including
Protoceratops were found near the affirm
mentioned sauropod enclosure posthumous
examination of all SCP 563 a instances
found that up to 79 percent of the
individuals found had a prion in their
system prior to their death testing on
this prayin
found it to be similar to a prion that
causes kuru suggesting that SCP 563 a
instances had been fed or were feeding
on meat of the same species notably most
species of Raptor found on site were
immune to this prime
addendum document 563 a double co5 the
following is a translation of a document
recovered from behind a picture frame in
the main office building an SCP 563 the
document was partially damaged by mold
however foundation linguists have been
able to reconstruct what they believe is
an accurate rendition of the document
dear name unknown as the Americans say
we have hit the jackpot windfall big
time
no more simple frozen meals for this
failing company the jungle you pointed
us to has given us quite a boon the meat
is delicious the fruit is unknown mostly
a synonym for delicious and the seafood
one of the cooks made stir-fry with
ginger and I suppose you would call them
shrimps and clams
but honestly I'm no paleontologist it
was the best thing I had ever tasted and
the eggs well we're having difficulty
finding unto fertilized ones the ones
that we do find either hatch or have
babies possibly embryos or zygotes in
them but the things that do hatch it
would make an American scientist most
likely paleontologist blush and then die
of joy we're sending back a few
specimens to the leader next stop
unknown next sentence indicates a
country to the north
most likely either Russia or Mongolia
northward we go with regards jazz song
okay I think that about does it for
today thank you all for listening if
indeed you still are and you were all
dismissed goodbye
[Music]
[Music]
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob the reclusive extrovert James
Sabah Chris all Pablo ice 917 Kareem el
ash mooing Justin day Thomas Morin Curie
kuma white crew and jayvo Jack witch
doctor crystal Roos my archive curator
Nick Joseph Lewis sue eggy agent vamp
King modding Drakkar the wanderer and
Joshua Proctor thank you all so much for
your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos well on some other
cool stuff as well visit patreon.com
forward slash the Volgin thank you
[Music]
you
[Music]